had to go to the bathroom and i held it  for so long the one moment that i went  to go a woman ran into the bathroom she  grabbed me by my wrist yanked me out i'd  never been pulled so strongly in my life  she pulled me and i ran for my life i  got to the stage i threw my vape i got  on there and i did my thing but yeah i  know i was definitely in the middle of a  big piss where me going tonight me going  to maybe a bar with locals and roaches  walking around you so emotional yes that  too it means a lot to me it was uh  something that we all imagined in the  beginning seven years ago eight years  ago does it also restore your faith in  humanity now it doesn't i think certain  tick tocks do that